thank you
[Music]
and this right here
is this one of those what color is this
dress no it's just a regular butt it's
white and blue but illusion this one
looks like a shark Gill is that a dude
this isn't even the thing you're already
ripping on her is that a dude no it's
not even the dress looks like a shark
Gill I didn't rip on nothing I'm just
looking at an optical illusion so I
think it's white and gold it's kind of a
popular thing for some women to when
they go out on dates or they go out
they they do that they get they put a
little uh butt shaper they do a lat
spread they wear they wear a butt shaper
I can't even tell the difference can you
go back yeah yeah yeah yeah look look at
uh well it's hard to see from this angle
but pattern sucks dude this is not
filled in right here the pattern might
be helping it why she gotta hold like a
peaky blinders pose
Arthur Weasley or Arthur [__] saying
it out loud
I'm seeing the show peaky blinders
what do you guys think about
she does have a try me pose huh
that's a dreamy full what do you guys
think about that what do you guys think
about uh putting on uh and it's
borderline like a prosthetic it's like
an extra I think if you start faking the
[__] that's a slippery slope I thought
girls already have those biker shorts
that have the pads that should make it
rounder do they like a butt pad thingy
because then you just take them off and
then you have no ass and then there's
chicken cutlets yeah yeah isn't the
chicken the the chicken cutlets actually
you know I digress I gotta say when the
whole Wonder Bra thing started happening
what's a Wonder Bra
uh it was just like literally yeah
Victoria so always
like two size bigger two sizes yeah so
for five wow so when I was in high
school and that came out and them Asian
girls suddenly started looking like
nicer I wasn't complaining I gotta admit
that I wasn't complaining it wasn't like
that's fake it was just more like that's
nicer to look with look at you know what
I mean is it though like as a man to
like think that that's what you're
getting and then in the bedroom it'd be
completely different I don't know any
guy at the last moment that goes ew
Because by the time you're there you're
already like infatuated and then it
comes off and you're like well that's
not what I expected but fine and also
maybe there might not be a second date
though maybe the wonderbot concept was
under the guise of function not just
like fashion you know what I mean it
wasn't just like a make me look better
it was like the concept and again I was
a teenager at the time so anything is an
idiot mind right but there's something
to the idea of like oh women have to
wear this therefore it's like that's
cool right but the idea of maybe like
making your ass bigger if there's no
function into it and it's purely
aesthetic I think that could also
trigger a different kind of thing in my
brain or just being like Oh you're like
it's very very shallow the idea of it
you know what I'm saying for me there's
an insecurity there maybe yeah for me
it's you do whatever you want to do but
you also have to live with whatever you
want to do so for example like if you
want to go to college and you want to
you have the hookups to every single
answer on the Scantron and you got a 4.0
cool you got your 4.0 but do you know
any of the knowledge you don't then you
live with you know so I'm like you can
shape whatever anything you want that's
on you you want to look good cool
visually you look awesome but at home
you know you don't look like that right
and then you got to face yourself
if you're cool with facing yourself then
that's cool too or you run the risk of a
guy going I was not expecting that I'm
going home that foot is too shaped I
think like a lot of these women who wear
shape were like that it helps with
certain dresses I will say that
um like if a dresser fits a certain way
and you can't wear like underwear or
undergarments you can wear that just so
that way it fits better as far as like
maybe a specific dress
um but I mean just be comfortable in
what you have and then just work towards
what you want I've never I've never seen
that means you actually got to put in
work and a lot of people don't want to
do that they want an easy fix I've never
seen it to the point where it was so
drastic
to the point where it was too drastic
like when girls be wearing the chicken
cutlet thingy on their on their thing
yeah like yeah their titties look more
good yeah but they're like when they
take off the bra it's not like they went
from like super big old D's to like
super flat nothings yeah I think there's
a difference
versus like faking exactly you know what
I mean exactly that's true it's just oh
it's just pushed up you know and I never
seen the fake butt thing where it was
like whoa what the hell is that Kim
Kardashian and then she takes off her
clothes and it's like Mr Mr [__]
Burns
dude longest back I've ever seen yeah
missed the [__] Birds
the heels are like that right yeah
because you could change six inches you
can pass six inches in height and that's
a [__] ton yeah but you see what you're
working with it's not like the heel is
like dressed to look like a person's
foot you know yeah
what the hell that is weird
guys are kind of asking for that just as
much as like the you know the I like
heels it is just crazy to see how many
Legos like all those accessories my wife
has when she wears certain dresses and
[__] like kind of what she was talking
about like all you get all these
products that are marketed just for you
know shaping a woman's butt like when my
wife has to wear a certain dress she has
to get like stick a tape yeah or these
[__] you know the things that cover
the nips and then because you can't wear
a bra and I'm like you got so many
[__] things you don't want the
underwear line when you wear the dress
So now too most I think most people are
like who cares with the nipple showing
now like sometimes that's an accessory I
want that covered up dude okay I want
that covered up you want to show your
nipples go ahead I see a lot of girls
with hard nipples in Waikiki that's a
thing what it's just the Hawaiian thing
yeah hard nipples are Regional yeah no
it's because all the all the Gen Z Girls
cover up something that is natural just
because it's now you're sexy you go girl
because I'm gonna throw up if I see it
dude yeah so let's say that it's not so
there's a difference
like women wearing stuff and they're
just out there and you just visually see
it like not that but like what if this
is something you're on a date with this
is a person that you're like and then
you go home and you have to peel off her
butt yeah and then you're like what be
like a problem if you were if like you
know you guys were getting into it and
she's like hang on like I said is this
like amplifier or is this like literally
like it's like molded like an ass it's
like two inches yeah oh so when you pull
it off the butt drops you gotta peel the
butt off it's not so much about like
that that's not fair I have questions as
to
to wear your mental
entire insecurities and like your state
of mind is at to do something to that
extreme then I'm like I'm like okay then
if that's the case then what else are
you struggling with and then how are we
gonna is this yeah and is this
synonymous to me wearing like tight
skinny jeans but then having like a roll
of quarters in there just to like or you
know like what the dudes have now
the dude's got like the chest this is a
roll of Dimes
things now
oh yeah right imagine a Korean yeah they
have the chest and the peck thing they
put that on they're wearing a jacket
they're going on a date chicks fill them
up oh [__] right and then they go home
and they're like oh wait a second after
I take out my clothes let me pull off
this theme that's yeah this
is
the [__] bird yeah
these are the same shade to me what's
the line though this is like girls with
wigs or extensions or eyelashes like all
that [__] where's the the fine line
between me it's up to that line I can
appreciate all of it that looks good
to me it's if that person can live with
it okay so anything I'm like it depends
on if you can live with it if you can
live with the extensions lipstick what I
mean unless it's like The Fresh Prince
of Bel-Air episode where they're [__]
stuck you know what I mean with the
nails here here's the eyelashes the
nails it's the wig it's the you know
what I mean and it's like oh
that's not normal
all at one time right you can handle a
little bit of anything in doses but if
it's all the whole thing and then
suddenly when you take the whole thing
away this is a completely different
Human Than like like clean and they are
but that's two for one question you got
two different people for one person okay
you know what that's optimism and I like
that because like it's the line this is
the reason I'm bringing it up is that uh
the popularity of this has skyrocketed
like crazy butts popular yeah yes games
yeah but like the idea that it's not new
this has been right skims are like
Amplified butt stuff no like skims is
just to like keep everything smooth body
shape keeps it tighter
it just goes in dude the fabric is
pretty sweet your thighs go tighter yeah
yeah because I be seeing those girls in
those yoga pants like and then you know
how influencers on Tick Tock or whatever
they'll show you like oh this is what it
looks like when my belly's relaxed and
then they take down their [__] and I was
like what the [__] it it creates like an
hourglass yeah well that's what people
like people like that [__] you know yeah
but then when they take off their pants
area you see the belly drop I was like
wow
if you look like that and you're wearing
those amplifiers you got hourglass discs
and you bag a man you take them into the
bedroom it don't [__] matter what
flops out afterwards you start taking
off some guys but that's what I feel
like that's all
that's why like so that's why like if
it's just if it's just to be fashionable
like that's not in your business how
they want to look if it's just visual
whatever but like if you're if you go
into a relationship or like your girl
wants to start doing that yeah that's
the question like is it well if you
already know what she looks like naked
then it's like yeah do whatever you want
[Music]